[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when I was young I found an orphaned
wolf cub in the forest 9r farm I felt if
I could instill rules the proper
boundaries I could harness a lot of
power of that beast
a few months later while hunting
we're fixing the damage the Avengers did
all those years ago Inhumans are sick
unlimited power that's dangerous it's
lethal
you are lucky to be alive come on Kamala
let em help you I'll take my chances
what if the Avengers were set up I think
you should see for yourself
mr. stark help us with this hi I'm sorry
who are you come on it's better be good
you tried to die for chimera have you
completely lost your senses
where were you all the world went to
hell this is our fault
all of ours you really think the world
is better without us yes it's always
been you running from who you are what
you are
[Music]
[Music]
what's up Marvel fans my name is Casey
Lynch and I'm editorial director at
Crystal Dynamics Marvel's Avengers war
table is your direct source for all
things Marvel's Avengers we've got a
great show lined up with new trailers
new details on one of our main villains
MODOK and advanced idea mechanics and
we'll take a first look at coop and war
zones if you've ever thought what is
this game or how does it work then this
is the show for you
let's get into it starting with a story
trailer in the aftermath of a day
everything changed you so-called heroes
transformed San Francisco into an
infectious gas filled quarantine zone
you unleashed disease powerful beings
that wreak havoc throughout our nation
so I ask you again dr. banner
do the Avengers pose a danger to society
yes I can promise you this I will use
this second chance to make aim we'll
find a cure for the inhuman disease
as a founding member of tech giant
advanced idea mechanics or aim George
tarlatan
dreamt of a world made better through
science but even as aim promises a cure
to ending in human infection and the
revolutionary adaptoid project offers a
worl protected by science tarleton a
victim of a day himself uses Ames
technological might and the public
sphere of Inhumans to convince the world
that the super-powered are
uncontrollable and cannot be trusted his
deranged obsession drives him to become
MODOK mental organism designed only for
killing when choosing a villain we knew
we needed someone who had the muscle and
mental capacity to become an Avengers
level threat we also wanted a new face
for modern Avengers fans big face but
comic fans no MODOK is anything but new
his origin in Marvel Lord dates back
more than 50 years to October of 1967 in
tales of suspense now with aim strive to
manipulate public fear and his ability
to control machines with his mind
tarlatan and aim are the most
sophisticated threat the Avengers have
ever faced but a teenage fan girl named
Kamala Khan doesn't trust aim in fact
she's convinced that aim is
experimenting on her fellow Inhumans
under the guise of finding a cure and
she believes George tarlatan was behind
the plot to discredit the Avengers and
she has proof as you pick up the trail
of the long disbanded Avengers you'll
advance the story of the single-player
campaign unlocking more and more hero
specific missions we know you've been
asking for new gameplay that's not from
a day we hear you so here's a
playthrough a part of a new Thor hero
mission called once an Avenger
you
[Music]
[Music]
we're here live with the aim experience
in Manhattan witnessing the return of
the Avengers foot they may appear to be
attacking the city keep rolling keep
rolling is it any coincidence that this
attack comes on the very day that aim is
supposed to unveil their promising new
adaptoid programs Oh
you're welcome
thank you
[Music]
you should know
wait is that for holy crap Thor who the
hell did you come from I was serving at
plumbing juice when it started raining
folks of metal from the scars believably
good to see you dramatic you did what
you were supposed to do forward gave up
your power you just forgotten
[Music]
something charlton cooked up to crack
[Music]
just like old times
aim drops at Simbel focus on those max
come on are you okay
don't worry she's up to it
kalimera still losing altitude so can
you hold it up with wind
[Music]
you killed
[Music]
we're the terrorists in the same
experience story not on my watch
the camara can't go down not again
bought us some drones heading for the
command deck got my hands full kid
just came back online it's working
[Music]
I can handle the Lord you don't have to
that's the whole point
[Music]
Starck has already been done Avengers
[Music]
and while Tony we're trying to restart
the engines but there's not enough power
we rather telling people impact hey
[Music]
once an Avenger is a great example of a
hero mission a single-player campaign
experience focusing on a specific
playable character hero missions give us
a chance to tell more of each heroes
story and showcase the variety and depth
of our hero designs let's take a quick
look at how Thor plays with the game's
combat systems players can stream
together combos of heavy and light
attacks or hold for signature attacks
combat versatility is one of Thor
strengths from making use of Mjolnir to
pin enemies from a distance or bringing
the sky down on his foes in addition to
core combat moves the god of thunder has
a wide variety of skills to unlock that
give him access to classic moves this is
one of our favorites manual targeting we
largely draw our influence from writer
Jason Aaron's run on the Mighty Thor
comic manual targeting allows you to
quickly mark your enemies for
bull's-eyes with mule NER and one by one
you can mark them and knock them down as
Milner comes back to you follow that up
with a powerful ground pound and you've
got a mighty combo manual targeting is a
great ranged attack but if
up-close-and-personal is more your style
go with the hammer spin or mule near
cyclone
heroes have three special heroic moves
assault ultimate and support when
designing our heroics we started with
the signature moves from the comics and
movies that we've always wanted to play
the assault heroic charges the fastest
and in some cases you can store multiple
charges to use strategically as a part
of your combos you can perform these
after charging your heroic meters with
normal attacks for instance Natasha's
assault her oak is widow's bite which is
an electroshock projectile move you
might recognize you can see Matt using
it right here Ichiro also has a unique
support heroic that's designed to
enhance co-op and team play for example
for support Warriors fury Letson channel
the power of the gods to supercharge his
OD force and grants a period of
invulnerability for nearby team members
you can see this in action and when
Ironman gets the buff as he flies
through Thor's support Ultimates take
longer to charge but they're definitely
worth the wait they have more screen
clearing power and some even have
residual effects like Thor's Bifrost
ultimate Thor's ultimate heroic
channel's the power of the nine realms
and his Bifrost taps into muscle hive to
bypass unbreakable shields allowing for
to use the power of the Bifrost bridge
to do maximum damage we know everyone
plays differently so we have melee
ranged aerial and ground combat skills
to tailor your hero to your play style
as your heroes are an experience they
gain access to new skills skill points
allow you to unlock new moves combos and
even new versions of attacks as you
build up your heroes you begin to see
how unlocking and mastering the separate
core skills offers a ton of depth and
variety on its own for every hero
and that's before year Perks artifacts
and any kind of later game progression
so why is all this important because it
means your Thor will play differently
than my Thor and my Hulk will play
different than yours another way to
customize your heroes is with gear we've
previously talked about the different
rarities and how perks will give you
powerful modifiers for even more
customization some perks apply special
damage like plasma or gamma or cos
status effects like shrink which will
shrink enemies and reduce damage to
defense you can see Iron Man using gamma
gear in this shot and eagle-eyed fans
probably noticed his laser sweep was
green instead of red no that wasn't a
bug when you have gamma gear equipped it
grants a bonus damage modifier and
changes the emissive color of your
attack and without green lasers we know
that if you look good you'll play good
the crystal team has really enjoyed
creating all new outfits for these
heroes and drawing from Marvel's 80-year
history to bring so many classic outfits
to the game each hero has dozens of
outfits drawn from some of the most
recognizable eras and story arcs you can
earn them over the course of the story
campaign by completing missions and
deciphering patterns there's an Iron Man
suit from the 2014 original sins
storyline or Donald Blake which is a nod
to an alias of Thor's who first appeared
in 1962 s journey into mystery issue 83
or Tony's stark tech outfit that was
inspired by the bleeding edge armor that
first appeared in invincible Iron Man
number 25 in 2010 while there are a ton
of outfits you'll learn just by playing
some will require completing iconic
mission chains to earn each heroes
iconic outfit and some outfits will only
be available in our online marketplace
you can even customize your attitude and
let out your inner Hulk with the right
emote
I don't think that's canon those are
just some of the ways you'll be able to
build and spec out your heroes ok I
think it's time for another trailer this
gives us a first look at how all that
customization is especially fun when you
play together
this is co-op and war zones they harvest
their powers georgie-boy is gearing up
for war programmable power under our
control No More Heroes entire worlds ooh
terrible danger time is here I can pull
some strings to spruce up the armory get
ourselves some new toys to play with
dangerous ones
[Music]
you got to get this bird in the air
before Ian comes looking for us
Jarvis is unencrypted in the schematics
and we'll get our tech heads on new gear
ASA
[Music]
[Music]
look at all this which nation state is a
bladed river war with
I don't stop them it's just one more
thing to regret on identity
you want to see powers there we go
[Music]
so far we talked about the story hero
missions and customization now let's
talk about war zones
war zones are missions which you can
play with up to a total of four players
or solo with an AI companion team made
up of your unlocked and levelled heroes
whether playing hero missions or war
zones
you always make forward progress with
your heroes on your Helicarrier you'll
use the wort able to launch missions
with a variety of objectives and
challenges as you saw on the co-op
trailer each mission is grounded in
story so whether you're in the campaign
or war zones you're always working
together to stop aim and rebuild the
resistance you get missions to Jarvis
Maria Hill Hank Pym and more characters
from Marvel history once you pick your
mission you'll board the Quinn jet where
you can match make switch heroes choose
your loadout and of course pick the
right look and attitude for the job as
you start playing missions across the
globe you'll realise aim has entrenched
themselves in cities and remote
locations alike all in the name of
research war zones range from wide-open
spaces designed for exploration and key
traversal to dense interiors with a
variety of objective based challenges
boss fights and rewards here's a mission
we saw on the coop trailer called to
tame a Titan where we can see some team
play there's this cool shot of Iron Man
but you may have missed Kamala and Hulk
performing a team finisher on that poor
guy back there when you max out some
larger enemies stunned meter - heroes
can come together to perform a team
finisher which gives you a chance to
take them down much faster teamwork
makes the dream work
living the hero life is all about
growing getting stronger and better
equipped to play smarter and there are
plenty of upgrades to help you do just
that as you progress through the
campaign you'll also be rebuilding and
upgrading the Chimera your Helicarrier
which is your own flying base
the resistance is a group who have
banded together in the five years since
a day some are inhuman and have powers
some are former shield agents who
refused to pledge allegiance to aim and
some just want to help you'll join their
cause in the field by working directly
with factions like the inhuman alliance
and shield agents dum-dum Dugan Nick
Fury and war earning faction reputation
will give you access to new challenges
new vendors and more powerful items
there will always be new threats on the
horizon so you want to ensure your
Avengers are ready for anything we've
talked about a lot today but that's kind
of the point this is a really big
ambitious game
Marvel's Avengers isn't just a global
high-stakes race to rebuild the Avengers
to save the Inhumans and uncover the
truth about aims plans that's just the
beginning this is a brand new original
Avengers single-player story that you
can enjoy on your own made the Crystal
Dynamics way but it's also an experience
you can play with your friends that will
grow as we add new heroes new regions
and new story all at no additional cost
[Music]
thank you for following us and believing
in us I want to give a big shout out to
our community thank you for caring and
telling us what you think we're
listening and its fans ourselves we're
all working every day to make marvel's
avengers worthy of your support please
stick around after the show to ask
questions and chat on behalf of the
whole marvel's avengers team thank you
for tuning in to the first marvel's
avengers war table in the coming months
we'll talk about our first post-launch
hero our upcoming beta and of course our
launch when marvel's avengers arrives
September 4th
I'm Casey Lynch and I'll see you next
time
you
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]